كلنا نفكر باشياء خطيره ورغم ذلك فنحن لا
نعرض حياتنا للنهايه لمجرد اننا نفكر
باشياء خطيره لكن الشيء الخطير الذي كنت
افكر فيه هو تعريض حياتي للنهايه
ولدت في عكا عام
وانتقلت بعدها للعيش في يافا مع عائلتي في
طفولتي كنت ادرس في مدرسه فرنسيه وذلك
ساعدني على الانفتاح على الاداب الاخرى
كنت انتمي الى عائله من الطبقه الوسطى
وكان والدي محاميا وفجاه انهارت هذه
العائله واصبحنا لاجئين غادرنا فلسطين الى
لبنان ولاحقا ذهبنا الى دمشق ودرست هناك
الادب العربي لكن تم استبعاد لاسباب
سياسيه
وعندها سافرت الى الكويت وبشرته هناك
القراءه والتاليف
جدا لانه جمع الحقول معرفيه متعدده ما
يتميز في غسان عن الكتاب الفلسطينيون
والعرب في تلك المرحله انه هو كان التقت
المتحرك في الساكن الساكن هو الحاله
البائسه الصعبه لا احد ينكرها ولكن هو شاف
انه عداله القضيه الفلسطينيه بتخليه يركز
على وين العوامل الجنينيه اللي بتعمل فعل
التغيير الفلسطيني
عمل لفلسطين عمل كبير كتير بمعنى انه عم
انه كتب تاسيس للادب الفلسطيني ما بعد
النحل يعني رجعوا اسسوا الوعي الفلسطيني
اظن ان تاثير الاكبر على كتاباتي يرجع الى
الواقع نفسه الى ما اشاهده من تجارب الناس
من حوله الى تعايشه في المخيمات مع الفقر
والبوس
كان قريب من الفلسطينيين من الناس البسطه
اننا نتعلم من الجماهير ونعلمها ومع ذلك
فانه يبدو
اننا لم نتخرج بعد من مدارس الجماهير
المعلم الحقيقي الدائم والذي في صفائر
روياه تكون الثوره جزءا لا ينفصم عن الخبز
والمائي واكف الكدح ونبض القلب غسان
كنفاني بدا كاتبا للقصه لكنه فيما بعد
استطاع ان يطلع اطلاعا كبيرا على التيارات
والمذاهب الادبيه في العالم وهذا ما مكن
غسان كنفاني من ان يقدم لنا عددا من
الروايات والقصص والدراسات الادبيه
والمقالات الصحفيه باعتباره كان صحفيا
ايضا اسلوب الكتابي تطور خلال الفتره
الواقعه بين عامي
1956 و
1962 كنت اكتب عن فلسطين كقضيه قائمه بحد
ذاتها ثم تبين لي اني اصبحت ارى في فلسطين
رمزا انساني متكاملا يميز روائيا انه هو
عمد الى التجريب الفني في كل مره كان
بيكتشف اسلوب فني جديد علشان يقدم افكاره
في وطن قومي يهودي بفلسطين
ومبرمجي فمعقول يصير اشي من دون مناعه
ايضا روايه هي لفتحه الطريق امام كيف نفكر
بهذا العدو ادبيا غسان يقصد مناقشه قضيه
الدم ما بصير مياه هاي النظريه ولا
الثقافه هي اللي بتقرب الانسان للوطن
مفهوم الوطن يعني يعني وطنيه الواحد تيجي
من الدم ولا من الثقافه
سالت ما هو الوطن وكنت اسال نفسي ذلك
السؤال قبل لحظه
اجل ما هو الوطن
هو هذان المقعدان اللذان ظله في هذه
الغرفه عشرين سنه الطاوله ريش الطاووس
سوره القدس على الجدار المزلاج النحاسي
شجره البلوط الشرفه ما هو الوطن
الى الجبهه الشعبيه لتحرير فلسطين وكان
الناطق الاعلامي لها المرحله كانت تحثم
على المثقف ان يكون مناضل مش كان هيدا
خيار اذا كنت انت مثقف مرتبط بشعبك مرتبط
باهلك مرتبط بعيلتك مرتبط بارضك بالارض
يلي طلعت منها ما كان في عندك خيار الا
تكون مناظره بس احد رموز ادب المقاومه
وغسان جسد المقاومه بشغله السياسي وبعمله
الادبي ووصلت القضيه الفلسطينيه لكل هدول
اكثر مما يمكن ان توصلوا للكتاب السياسي
لما اسرائيل
تقرصيات بعينها هي ايضا تغتال مفكرين
وكتاب وادباء ومش بس سياسيين طبعا اللعبه
بالاخير وصلت لذروته لما تحول الكاتب لبطل
ان كل قيمه كلماتك كانت في انها تعويض
صفيق وتافه لغياب السلاح وانها تنحدر الان
امام شروق الرجال الحقيقيين الذين يموتون
كل يوم في سبيل شيء احترمه